the new gen witcher 3 has a shiny new
release window and the last of us remake
might have one too
it's almost time to play my favorite
game of all time again today cd projekt
red confirmed that the witcher 3's
playstation 5 and xbox series x and s
version will be released in q4 2022 that
means it'll launch in the october
december period unless the devs decide
to push it again the new generation
version of the acclaimed rpg was delayed
indefinitely back in april when cd
projekt revealed the development was
shifting from saber interactive's
russian team to cd projekt red itself cd
projekt condemned russia's attacks on
ukraine and suspended sales and services
in the country though whether or not
this had anything to do with the shift
in development is unknown just like
cyberpunk 2077's next generation version
the witcher 3s will take advantage of
the additional horsepower of those
systems to make the game look and run
better the ps5 and xbox series x and s
versions also come with all previously
released expansions as well as new
content inspired by the netflix show and
also like cyberpunk anyone who has
bought the witcher 3 gets the upgrade
for free and while we're on the subject
of new versions of old games let's talk
about the last of us remake we're still
getting reports that a remake of 2013's
the last of us is in the works and it
seems like it's scheduled to launch
sometime this year the remake will
supposedly launch in the holiday season
which is currently fairly empty
following starfield's delay on the may
18th episode of the kind of funny games
cast games beats jeff grubbs said quote
i keep hearing that the last of us
remake is coming out this year the last
of us remake this holiday several
sources have already reported this story
so there's a good chance there may be
some truth to it in a tweet back in
january freelance writer and games
industry insider tom henderson first
reported the last of us remake would
launch in the latter half of 2022.
bloomberg collaborated on this
prediction and followed up with its own
report in april also in april a linkedin
listening hinted that developer naughty
dog may be working on a remake for the
last of us the listing mentions quote qa
testing and development support plus
level point of contact for unannounced
remake project but i guess we'll have to
wait a little bit longer to find out
switching gears to a bit of weird news
call of duty warzone is currently home
to a rematch between king kong and
godzilla an operation monarch and has
discovered and banished to the not safer
work section of reddit's call of duty
war zone subreddit it is possible to hop
in a helicopter and attack kong's upper
thigh section while kong's model in war
zone isn't anatomically correct you're
technically still attacking the king's
crown jewels to efficiently farm
experience points other methods might be
easier but none are as hilarious season
3's operation monarch event ends on may
25th so let me know in the comments if
you've been enjoying it so far and what
you want from the next warzone event